hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American drama mystery
film called the game spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
Nicholas van Orton is a businessman
living alone in a large Mansion outside
San Francisco is highly successful but
the success has come at the cost of his
family life when the movie opens he is a
lonely divorced and bored out of his
mind Nicholas's brother Conrad is his
only living relative but they share a
strange relationship and haven't met in
two years one morning Nicholas is told
that Conrad has been trying to schedule
a meeting with him for days that
afternoon he shows up unannounced at a
restaurant and reveals that he is there
to wish Nicholas a happy birthday
Nicholas gets yet another surprise when
Conrad presents him with an unusual gift
a voucher for a strange game offered by
a company called CRS Nicholas initially
thinks Conrad is playing an unfunny joke
on him but the younger brother makes him
promise he will visit the CRS office at
least once this week the next day when
Nicholas has almost forgotten about the
voucher he arrives at an office building
for a meeting coincidentally this also
happens to be the place where the CRS
office is located he walks in and is
greeted by an employee named Jim he
shares Conrad around the office and
tells him about the pregame protocol but
doesn't give him any insight into what
the actual game is Nicholas is annoyed
that his questions are being answered
but the mystery of it all keeps him
interested in the game hence without
even knowing what the game is he agrees
to play the pregame procedure includes
engaging in a four-hour long personality
test Nicholas clears up his schedule to
go through with it and is asked a bunch
of strange questions like if he
sometimes hurts small animals and if he
prefers boobs butts or balls after a
length the entiresome test he is told
that he will get a call if he is
selected for the game he spends the next
day with his buddies from the tennis
club and hears them talk about CRS it
turns out that both of his friends have
played the CRS game and they wish they
could experience it again Nicholas
inquires what exactly the game is but
even his friends refuse to answer the
question later in a meeting he gets a
call from CRS and is told his applique
station has been rejected by now
Nicholas is so excited to play the game
that the news disappoints him ah should
have said I like butts on his drive home
at night he finds a life-sized clown
doll in the turnaround and decides to
bring it home while trying to check who
left it outside he finds a key attached
to the Clown's tongue strangely enough
the key has the CRS logo on it which
means that despite the phone call he
received the game has started as
Nicholas further inspects the clown he
hears a voice asking him if he will
spend the entire evening dissecting the
poor doll a surprised Nicholas looks
around only to find out that the
newscaster is talking to him through the
television he tells Nicholas the rules
of the game revealing that he will find
other objects like the key which he
should always keep close to until the
game is over Nicholas also discovers the
doll has a camera hidden in it which the
newscaster is using to look at him he
breaks the Clown's neck to get rid of
the camera and goes to sleep starting
the next day several minor
inconveniences bother him he sees
clown-shaped objects everywhere keeps
encountering people who stare at him as
if they know something and his shirt is
ruined because of a CRS pen in his
pocket soon the inconveniences start
affecting him deeply when he loses a
business deal because he isn't able to
open his briefcase in a desperate
attempt he tries using the CRS key but
it doesn't work either at the end of the
day he goes to a restaurant for dinner
where he encounters a waitress named
Christine she accidentally spills wine
on his shirt and is fired by her boss
immediately seconds later Nicholas
receives the bill and on it is written
don't let her get away he figures the
message is about Christine and rushes
outside to find her in a dark alleyway
Nicholas stumbles upon a sick man
Christine appears out of nowhere and
insists they take him to the hospital as
if On Cue a police car passes by and
helps them as the police the ambulance
and the paramedics reach the hospital
even stranger things start happening the
lights suddenly turn off and when they
turn back on Chris Dean and Nicholas are
the only people in the parking lot
Nicholas figures that this is also part
of the game I don't know Nicholas sounds
like a stretch the duo finds a broken
elevator which starts working when
Nicholas uses the CRS key to fix it he
then tells Christine about the game he
signed up for which she thinks is a
sadist activity for rich people the two
somehow managed to get out of the
elevator and find out they are in the
CRS building on trying to break into the
offices they trigger an alarm and have
to escape before being found Nicholas
feels bad for dragging Christine into
this mess and takes her to his Mansion
they share a brief conversation before
she takes a shower and calls herself a
taxi right before leaving Christine
reveals that she was offered four
hundred dollars to spill wine on him
earlier she should have asked for at
least twice that but she didn't see the
person who asked her to do it Nicholas
thanks her for telling him and wishes
her goodbye the following morning he is
woken up by a call and finds out that he
left his credit card in a hotel lobby
last night confused because he never
went to a hotel Nicholas goes to
retrieve the card to his utter confusion
the staff recognizes him and escorts him
to his room which he allegedly used last
night as well Nicholas finds the room an
absolute mess with bottles of alcohol
and illegal pills spread everywhere an
explicit video plays on TV and there are
polaroid pictures of naked ladies lying
on the table but what surprises Nicholas
the most is that his case is on the
table as well and has been opened by
someone he quickly cleans up the mess
and drives back to his office knowing
that his business reputation finances
and safety are all at risk without
wasting much time he calls his attorney
Sam and orders him to find out
everything he can about the CRS he also
finds a glass breaking device inside an
envelope that he found in the hotel room
as well returning home at night Nicholas
wants to go straight to bed after
everything that has happened however he
soon realizes someone has broken into
his Mansion the walls are filled with
graffiti and the place doesn't even look
like his house anymore just when
Nicholas picks up the phone to call the
police the banging on the door startles
him it is none other than his brother
Conrad who is just as frantic as he is
Conrad hadn't been answering any of
Nicholas's phone calls which the little
brother explains is because he doesn't
trust anyone these days they drive away
in Nicholas's car not feeling safe in
The Mansion anymore Conrad then reveals
that he is tired of playing the CRS game
that has taken his life by storm he
wants to get rid of them and has paid
them a lot of money but to no avail
suddenly the car gets a flat tire and
Conrad finds a bunch of CRS keys in the
car assuming that his brother is also
with the CRS he runs away Nicholas tries
his best to stop him but eventually gets
in a taxi deciding to finally go to the
police in the next scene the taxi driver
misses an exit revealing that he is with
the CRS as well Nicholas panics as the
driver jumps out of the car and lets the
vehicle fall into the river Cannonball
[__] the car starts filling up with
water when Nicholas remembers he has the
glass breaking device using the device
he manages to save his own life and
swims to safety with no one else to turn
to Nicholas finds Christine's address
and goes to meet her they talk for a
while before he notices that a lamp's
price tag is burning inside it he finds
it strange that the lamp looks old but
the price tag is still intact soon he
starts noticing other stuff around the
house that makes it seem like it is a
stage rather than a home the faucet
doesn't work and the books on the
shelves are fake too Christine's not
even a real nerd when Christine comes
outside it is clear that she is still
working for the CRS Nicholas confronts
her and finds out that they are being
watched the CRS employees start firing
at them through the window but the duo
manages to escape through the back door
on their way to someplace safe Christine
reveals that CRS has used Nicholas's
personality tests to figure out his
passcodes and all his money has been
transferred to a foreign dummy account
Nicholas checks his balance only to find
out that she is telling the truth
although he is still adamant about
getting his money back Christine says it
is possible because she has seen this
happen to many people next they stop at
Christine's real house where she claims
that she was threatened to take the job
however Nicholas no longer believes her
his doubt is proven when he feels dizzy
and discovers that she spiked his drink
when Nicholas wakes up a day later he
finds himself entombed alive in a
cemetery in Mexico he has no passport
and no money to get back home after
wandering around asking for help for a
day he finally finds a truck going to
San Francisco in the next scene he
reaches his Mansion which is now for
sale unable to trust anyone in his life
he decides to meet his ex-wife Elizabeth
they meet at a cafe where Nicholas
apologizes for how he treated her when
they were together I'm sorry with that
out of the way can I have some money
just when he thinks his life is over
Nicholas sees an advertisement on TV
where the actor is Jim the CRS employee
who assisted him last week Nicholas
locates Jim with his kids in an aquarium
and threatens him the man scared for his
life takes Nicholas to the crs's real
office he is not shocked when he sees
several familiar faces in the crowd who
he has met in the past week but his eyes
stop when he locates Christine he holds
her hostage and brings her to the
Rooftop in a panic Christine finally
reveals that they are still in the game
organized by CPR with his brother Conrad
his finances are intact and his family
and friends are waiting on the other
side of the door to surprise him and
congratulate him for completing the game
however Nicholas no longer believes
Christine the door bursts open and he
shoots the first person he sees who
happens to be Conrad bearing an open
bottle of champagne Conrad dies and
Nicholas leaps off the roof devastated
at what he just did as he falls
Nicholas's life passes before his eyes
he smashes through a glass roof and
lands on a giant airbag it was set there
almost as if someone was expecting him
to fall the emergency medical
technicians come to his Aid not even
seconds later carefully removing him
when Nicholas gains Consciousness he
finds himself in a ballroom full of his
friends family and every person involved
in his game including Conrad everything
that has happened to him from the day he
found the clown until now has really
been just a game all along Conrad
explains that he initiated the game to
get his brother to embrace life it's a
good thing he jumped off of that side of
the building he says Nicholas bursts
into tears relaxes and enjoys the party
once his shock has dissipated how did
you guys get down here so fast anyway he
asks no one knows a while later he sees
that Christine has left the party so he
follows her outside your taxi where she
tells him her real name is Claire he
asks her to dinner but she says no I was
paid to do this but then she offers to
have coffee with him at the airport
before her flight takes her to her next
game assignment in Australia this
movie's plot is a little insane but it's
also a David Fincher must watch I
recommend it highly subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching